blastlight is the world's smallest
and most convenient uvc disinfection
light to help
keep you safe against covid19
i take mine everywhere i go go to
davidpakman.com
light to get it for 40 percent off the
link is down below
blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person
by letting you read or listen to an
entire nonfiction book in just 15
minutes
you can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription
by going to blinkist.com david pakman
so republicans have blocked even
debating
and discussing this major voting rights
bill that we've been talking about now
for
quite some time and we are really now
getting into sort of the most disgusting
and destructive
of american politics and of course huge
blame
goes directly to the republicans who
voted against
even debating the voting rights bill but
also we can't ignore the fact that
the great negotiation that joe biden
has claimed he would be able to do has
not even led to a debate about the
voting rights bill and we're going to
have video from the floor of the senate
uh and and much more and in fact maybe
we'll even uh start there
this is the uh moment where
uh kamala harris who presided over the
senate during this vote
um announced that uh the bill was
uh it wasn't we were not moving forward
into debate take a look at this the a's
are 50
the nays are 50. three-fifths of the
senators duly chosen
and sworn not having voted in the
affirmative
the motion is not agreed to now
what you have to understand when you um
evaluate this is that there really are
two completely different realities on
this issue
mitch mcconnell for example came out and
said
we don't even really have a voting
rights issue in this country
there aren't even people trying to
suppress
the ability of individuals to vote he
said this i guess with what
for mitch mcconnell counts as a straight
face let's take a look at what mitch
mcconnell had does that i mean how do
you say this with a straight face
how do you have the uh gumption and uh
i mean the tolerance for cringe to come
out and say the following
and many of you have written about the
subject of big lies
well the big biggest lie being told
in american politics in recent weeks
has been that the states are involved in
a systematic effort
to suppress the vote that's just a
why why would anyone think that that's
going on i mean other than the fact that
republicans have been openly admitting
it since
at least 2012 when mike terzai said
voter id is going to make it
so that mitt romney wins pennsylvania
and then everything else that happened
in the nine years that followed
and the 250-something bills across the
country
those arguments are being made by people
who obviously haven't read any of these
new state laws
because that's not happening as we all
know we had the biggest turnout
uh last year since 1900 now that's a red
herring
that's a complete and total biggest
turnout since 1900 how many people lived
in the united states in 1900s so
there's three or four different reasons
why that's not a good argument
number one as the population continues
to get larger and larger you would
expect more and more people to vote
trump often points to hey i got 75
million votes he really got 74.
uh that you know that that makes it hard
to believe that i lost given that 74
million people voted for me well even
more people voted for joe biden
uh and in addition to that we don't know
how many people wanted to vote
so it's just a complete and total red
herring let's just look at a little bit
more of this
there is no effort in any state in
america
to suppress votes based upon
suppression of minority uh participation
so that's a complete and total lie i
mean it couldn't be it couldn't be a
more dishonest thing to say
um so let's look at a little bit of the
reporting about this
cnn reporting senate republicans block
signature democratic election bill in
key
test vote saying that senate democrats
suffered a loss when republican
opposition
sunk their signature voting and election
bill during a key test vote
underscoring the limits of the party's
power with the narrowest possible
senate majority a procedural vote to
open debate was defeated by 50 50
falling short of the 60 votes needed
democrats were united in favor after
securing joe manchin support but
republicans were united against it
causing the measure to fail to advance
democratic senators have pitched the
legislation as a necessary counter to
state-level efforts to restrict voting
access
republicans have decried it as a
partisan power grab and a federal
overreach into state voting and election
systems the article goes on to say
senate democrats are already beginning
to map out their next steps to draw
attention to the issue and put the focus
on a critical battleground state
georgia now one of the lies that they
are already telling
about georgia is hey listen voter
purges are normal this is one of the
techniques
or tactics that is being used by
republicans
to hurt democrats in elections and it is
to purge voter rolls but to say
every state does it now it's true that
every state does it
but with far less restrictive barometers
than what georgia is putting in place
and so you really have to look at the
details and this is one of those issues
where
if you're not following it relatively
closely
you're not going to understand why the
bullet points
from republicans fall short and this
everybody does it
one is is uh really a um
an important example an illuminating
example which is they
insist every state has a system for
deciding
who should no longer be considered an
active registered voter and it depends
on
how recently you have voted and other
factors
what's being done in georgia is far more
aggressive and it's being done
in a very tailored way that while in an
overt way
it doesn't target minority voters it's
focused on those more likely to be
voting for democrats who happen to
disproportionately be
non-white voters so i get it people are
busy people are working people have
lives
so unless you're following it closely
you would not necessarily understand why
the claims that are being made are so
deceptive now i want to talk about one
other thing here
which is the filibuster aspect of this
there is a good article in the la times
an editorial by the times editorial
board which says senate republicans
won't even consider voting rights
the filibuster must go and it makes
sense that there is increased pressure
to do away with or modify the filibuster
because it's not even that they're
voting against the bill they're voting
against debating the bill and you need
60 vote votes in order to move forward
they wrote yesterday as expected debate
on a bill to protect voting rights was
blocked in the senate
when democratic sponsors failed to
garner 60 votes
but in reaching out to centrist joe
manchin democrats indicated they were
open to compromise
the shameful reaction of senate
republicans on the other hand
demonstrated that they are willing to
ignore laws
approved by republican-controlled
legislatures that make voting harder
those measures reflect the lingering
malign influence of donald trump's big
lie
that the 2020 election was stolen
um they go on to say uh about the
filibuster
and i want to find the exact point where
that is
um after tuesday's vote schumer
said that it represented the starting
gun
not the finish line mansion and other
and another democratic senator kirsten
cinema of arizona
have resisted the idea of abolishing the
filibuster but if republican senators
continue to stone wall reasonable
legislation
to protect the right to vote those two
reluctant democrats
must be pressed to recognize that at
least we're protecting democracy is
concerned
the filibuster must go and this is
absolutely and totally correct now
whether the filibuster must go in total
which potentially is going to have
repercussions
against democrats when republicans
invariably
take control again um at least
in practical terms you either need to
reform it to require a talking
filibuster
you either need to require the 40 no
votes to be in the senate at all times
in order to continue
something absolutely has to be done i
think at this point
it's been clear you know if republicans
and democrats
were equal in their willingness
to do whatever needs to be done to move
a bill forward
then maybe we wouldn't be having this
conversation but democrats have shown
that they are not willing to do what
needs to be done
uh in the way that republicans are to
get
moving forward on legislation that they
claim
is important to them so something is
going to have to be done to the
filibuster it absolutely is time
and again if republicans said
we believe we have a really strong case
why this bill should not pass and we
plan not to support it but let's debate
the bill
and then make their case against the
bill during the debate i would have a
different perspective
but they're saying no to even debating
the bill something has to be done
and the filibuster is going to have to
be a big piece of that
let's talk about the new york city
mayoral primary yesterday we had the
democratic mayoral primary in new york
city
and the republican mayoral primary in
new york city
there were high hopes among some that
former democratic presidential candidate
andrew yang
would do well in the democratic primary
canned
uh new york city mayoral race he came
out to a fast start polling really
really well in early polls
although that started to fade uh part of
the belief
that the fade of andre yang was because
of early name recognition he jumped
ahead because of early name recognition
from the democratic primary
um also questions about uh i guess we
would call it the authenticity of andrew
yang as a new yorker and and i
there were all sorts of kind of
xenophobic overtones to that there is no
question
that there was an aspect of the
opposition to accepting andrew yang as a
real new yorker
came from some anti-asian xenophobia
and also there was the sense that andrew
yang
having lived out of the city for a long
time
was not a real new yorker in that sense
as well
disaggregating some xenophobia from the
accurate understanding of andrew yang's
residence a complicated and difficult
thing and important not to
invalidate any aspect of that because
all of it were important asp
all of those aspects were relevant but
ultimately it did not go well
uh andrew yang the results as we have
them right now
have eric adams uh leading it is a
ranked choice um election and right now
you have eric adams leading at just shy
of 32 percent on the democratic
side with maya wiley up close to 10
points behind
at 22 katherine garcia
closely behind maya wiley in third place
at 19 and a half percent and then
pretty significantly further down with
only uh about a third of the support of
the leading candidate eric adams
andrew yang at 11.7
scott stringer and diane morales
combining for just shy of eight percent
over on the republican side curtis sliwa
quite a well-known face and
figure in new york city now for decades
of course of guardian angels fame curtis
lee what easily winning the republican
primary
with about 72 percent of the vote over
fernando mateo
here is a video of andrew yang who is
all about
math and the numbers rightly coming out
last night and saying
i don't have the numbers i simply don't
have the numbers take a listen to this
campaign but you all know i am
a numbers guy right i'm someone who
trafficks
in what's happening
uh by the numbers and i am not going to
be
the next mayor of new york city based
upon the numbers that have come in
tonight right
i am conceding this race
though we're not sure ultimately who the
next mayor is going to be
but whoever that person is i will be
very happy to work with them campaign
now a bunch of people coming out and
saying
you know what what what pomposity from
andrew yang
why would the eventual mayor work on
anything with the
fourth place finisher in the democratic
primary i didn't see it that way i saw
it simply as an act of good faith i
don't think that is a big deal i think
the more interesting story however is
how new york city is an interesting
place
in that the voters really did not seem
to care
about the name recognition of andrew
yang it helped him
early uh but it did not carry him to the
finish line and now we are going to see
um the general election get going new
york city
interesting as a it's not necessarily a
barometer nationally but there are a lot
of things in new york city
that relate to issues that many cities
across the country
are dealing with there are questions now
about how to deal with
what are widely perceived to be
short-term but certainly upticks in
certain types of crime and later today
joe biden is going to have a big event
related to gun violence
um there are also uh questions about
you know there there's been a um
a sort of bifurcation at the local and
semi-local level
about how politics should be focused in
the united states there are all these
national issues and cultural issues that
are getting a lot of attention when you
watch fox news and cnn and msnbc
and there have been attempts to insert
those
as the important issues into local races
in some places to a degree it's worked
where local races become about
will the city council boycott israel
or will we uh make a statement
about critical race theory as examples
but what i am seeing in new york city
is that voters really seem to care much
more about
local economic issues local issues of
public transit
and rent prices and really that
nitty-gritty which takes me back to the
james carville 1990s perspective of it's
the economy stupid
it's not seeming to me like making local
races
about national cultural or even
irrelevant to the local race foreign
policy issues
that seems to be uh coming through in
the results that we're seeing
in new york city so we're going to
follow the race even though it's a local
race because it has a lot of
national implications let me know your
thoughts about what happened to andrew
yang in new york city
um i laid out what i think held him back
let me know what you think you can find
me on twitter at deepakman we're going
to take a quick break and we've got
really just a packed program for you
today
one of our sponsors is blast light the
smallest and most
convenient uv disinfection light on the
market
covet is not over there are new variants
there might be future resurgences so of
course
it's still important to take precautions
keep yourself safe keep people around
you
safe uvc lights have been proven to
safely and rapidly kill bacteria
mold fungi and viruses including covid19
blast light is a convenient keychain uvc
light that you can take
wherever you go i keep it attached to my
keys
it goes everywhere with me it's easy to
use it disinfects any surface in just
seconds
with a really long battery life and it's
rechargeable i've looked at a bunch of
different uvc light options
and this is by far the most compact and
portable one out there
blast light is normally ninety nine
dollars but my audience can get it for
forty percent off
which comes to fifty nine fifty when you
go to davidpakman.com
blastlight the link is underneath this
video
remember that the david pakman show is
an independent media program does depend
on your support i would love it if you
grabbed a membership on my website
join pacman.com you know we've had a
number of examples over the last
couple of weeks to a couple of months
of different things being equated to
being like the holocaust or like
world war ii or like historical attacks
on jews
and incorrectly so and now the sort of
natural
and and predictable next step in this
is taking place which is that we're
starting to see segments on right-wing
media
saying that teaching critical race
theory
or certainly critical race theory being
part of the national understanding of
how things work
is like the holocaust we're going to
have a clip of this
with right-wing radio host michael
savage now i do feel
i know that some people get angry when i
do the disclaimers i feel that it's
necessary here
i am a uh a critic of critical race
theory
i've critiqued critical race theory
along the lines that have critiqued
other theories that come out of the
post-modernist and post-structuralist
ideology i've critiqued critical race
theory as reductive
but critical race theory is not like the
holocaust it's it's
uh that that's a wild and crazy thing to
say
uh the daily beast summarizes news max
goes
there critical race theory is the road
to death camps for white people
right-wing radio talker michael savage
declared the obscure academic theory
akin to the holocaust
prompting a supportive response from a
newsmax tv host
far-right radio host michael savage took
conservatives latest moral panic
to a bonkers new level during a monday
night news max appearance warning that
the teaching of so-called critical race
theory in schools
is akin to exactly what was done to the
jews in germany now that is not true
we're going to look at the video clip
michael savage is a guy we've covered on
the program for a long time
he is desperate to maintain some level
of relevance
and comparing things to the holocaust
especially when you yourself are jewish
and remember that that's something that
the right is playing up michael savage
is jewish um
that makes it get more attention it
doesn't make it any more accurate let's
take a listen to this
and by the way the people who decry the
identity politics
say i don't know should we listen to
savage because he is jewish after all
maybe he can tell us what things are
like the holocaust here we go
i my blood spoiling listening to chuck
todd i wanted to reach through the
screen and smack him in the face
this is by the way if you're not
familiar with michael savage this is how
he normally talks
and it's just a way that he it's part of
his his shtick essentially
to talk in this he's just constantly
outraged at everything everybody
does he have children can you imagine
having a little child who goes to school
and is told that he's no good his race
is no good
he's evil his parents are evil his
nation is evil
these are the same sobs who elected us
for 20 years
about don't be a bully tolerate
everything
and now they're beating up white
children in school rooms
and i'm not going to mince words you can
cut me off if you have to i know you
probably agree with me i can't take this
anymore
and there's only one solution to it sue
the goddamn
schools if they do it to your child for
child abuse
now when he says if they do it to your
child
for child abuse um i
have said before i do think that
as a starting point uh teaching
children that they are
in some way part of a bad group because
of the color of their skin
i'm against that and that's bad for the
most part
critical race theory is taught to
college students
and only in certain relevant classes
that college students have chosen to
take
what michael savage is referring to
which exists
very anecdotally and i would be against
it but it is not really the issue
is certain exercises that have been done
in elementary or junior high schools
um which uh start to
sort of frame the question of
race and goodness and badness in a way
that i don't think
is useful or productive in any way to
bettering race relations but remember
that this is part of the ruse
the vast majority of what would fall
under the guise of critical race theory
is being taught to college students
and it is being taught as theory it is
not being taught as
you were bad for this reason or that
reason that relates to your
skin color so the whole framing here is
wrong but let's get to the really crazy
part
you will win because that's the only way
to stop this these children are being
humiliated
and hurt and damaged for life by a
psychotic
woman who came up with this lie called
critical race theory
which is nothing but racism towards
white people
no other race is targeted i could go on
and i could go on and on i've studied
history i know where this starts i know
where it ends
it started in the same kind of thing
started in germany the jews were no good
the jews did this the jews did that
the next thing you knew they were being
excluded from swimming pools
they didn't put them in concentration
camps overnight i studied this
intimately what's really interesting
about that the analogy to the holocaust
is completely wrong
but michael savage says something really
interesting there
which is he says it didn't happen
overnight
that phrase very accurately describes
the creeping authoritarianism and
nuttery that we saw under donald trump
if on the day after trump was elected in
2016 i had told you
by the end of this trump will be trying
to steal an election he clearly lost
um trying to use the department of
justice and all of these different
uh um uh aspects of government to do his
bidding
demanding that the supreme court do x
y and z all of the different mishandling
a pandemic during which he will
suggest that um uh infected americans be
sent to guantanamo bay nobody would have
believed it if i had said that on you
know november 8th of 2016 or whatever
the date was
but it slowly creeps in to the point
where by the time those things were
happening
the response was nowhere near what it
should have been
it doesn't apply here to critical race
theory but
it would have applied if michael savage
had talked about this in relation to
trump's creeping authoritarianism just a
few more seconds here
i am jewish i know how this starts
attacks
that's identity politics by the that's
the identity politics they decry
because he's jewish he must be right
about what things are like the holocaust
on white people is exactly what was done
to the jews in germany in the 30s
don't fall for this garbage this is the
road to the death camps
stand up to these bastards and sue them
yeah
so there is michael savage and it is yet
another analogy
to the holocaust that makes absolutely
no sense and the sad thing about this is
there there are real serious critiques
of critical race theory as an academic
theory
when you go to this is like jews being
excluded from swimming pools
and the precursors to concentration
camps
you just lose it and i would i would
actually
respect one of these right-wingers in
their opposition to critical race theory
much more
if they just levied a sober and sensible
critique that's not what we're seeing
from people like michael savage really
interesting leaked documents
showed that at least in some contexts
the us government is considering
socialists uh terrorists
alongside sort of neo-nazis this is a
very very interesting report that i want
to look at with you
today from the intercept written by ken
clippenstein
u.s military training document says
socialists
represent terrorist ideology a navy
training document
asks anarchists socialists and neo-nazis
represent which terrorist ideological
category we're going to look at the
document in a moment the article
explains
a navy county terror a navy
counter-terrorism training document
obtained exclusively by the intercept
appears to conflate socialists with
terrorists
and lists the left-wing ideology
alongside neo-nazis
a section of the training document
subtitled study questions
includes the following anarchists
socialists and neo-nazis represent which
terrorist
ideological category the correct answer
is
political terrorists a military source
briefed on the training told me
let's take a look at the document
briefly this is a trainee guide
it has an introduction which explains
that the assignment sheet is designed to
assist the student
in attaining knowledge necessary to
perform the duties
as an assigned anti-terrorism officer
and one of the study questions is indeed
the third question
anarchists socialists and neo-nazis
represent
which terrorist ideological category
and as ken clippenstein says in the
article
political terrorists is the answer
that is there um
it's just ineffective training because
whoever is directing the navy
anti-terror curriculum
would rather vilify the left than
actually protect
anything said the military official who
spoke to ken
who is not authorized to speak publicly
despite the fact that the most prominent
threat
is domestic right-wing terror
the article also notes both the fbi and
department of homeland security have
identified white supremacists as the
deadliest terror threat to the u.s we've
covered that extensively before
in october 2020 dhs issued its first
annual homeland threat assessment report
stating that white supremacists were
exceptionally lethal and will remain the
most persistent and legal lethal threat
in the homeland in september fbi
director christopher wray
said the white supremacists have been
responsible for the most lethal attacks
over the last decade and that they
comprise the biggest chunk of our
domestic terrorism portfolio so
there's definitely more here that we
don't know
but i can't think of any reason that you
would have neo-nazis and socialists in
the same
category now somebody if if i were to
steal man this and come up with the best
possible explanation
uh for why they would be in the same
category and again i don't think this is
a good
uh steel manning of it but one could say
while you can have a neo-nazi ideology
and not go and commit terrorist acts uh
and you can also have a socialistic
ideology and not go and commit terrorist
acts both
are ideologies which if taken
to a perverted end point could
lead people to commit real-world acts of
violence but
i think it's essentially bs um
socialism you know i i am not a
socialist i don't believe
that socializing the means of production
and that's saying that
uh if one starts a business and
buys all of the equipment and rents the
office space
and uh takes the legal risk and on and
on and on
um that as they hire employees they
should be forced to divvy up ownership
of that business to everybody like i
just don't agree with that
um i think it's okay for markets to
direct
uh resources in most cases
although there are some areas like
education and health care
and in some senses maybe housing where
we should take them
at least partially out of the market uh
or completely in some cases like i'm i'm
right there
you know with with that but i am not a
socialist
uh i just don't see how that leads to
so-called terrorism in the way that
neo-nazi ideology does now i understand
there's many neo-nazis who
just sort of like sit at home and they
you know maybe tweet stuff or post stuff
but they
don't actually commit any real world
acts of terror i understand that
but i really even in trying to defend
this
um as strongly as i could imagine one
could
the inclusion of socialist beliefs and
neo-nazi beliefs under the same category
it doesn't make any sense to me and so
i'd be curious to hear from people in
the audience
um can how can you can you come up with
some way
to defend this and i'm seeing
one other defense which is kind of
integrating socialism socialist
beliefs with antifa and saying well
antifa does real world violence um
okay but i i i think it's still a
stretch because
while i think it's relatively
uncontroversial to say
that antifa is not just based in
anti-fascist beliefs but
heavily inspired to some degree by
marxism
including socialism on the list of
terrorism seems like five or six steps
forward from that like i i did the best
i could to say
what is a way that we could defend this
um i can't think of one so i want to
hear from you and we'll have more
on this on the david pakman show
instagram which you can find
at david pakman show it's not making
sense to me guys
it seems completely wacky to include
neo-nazism and socialism under the same
umbrella let me know your thoughts
i'll follow up if i have uh some
interesting responses
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly what one of
my favorite apps lets you do it's called
blinkist and what they do is take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down
into text or audio that you can consume
in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the
important core insights from each book
so it's perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for
if there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blinkist to get
a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
nonfiction book
in just 15 minutes i recently read a
brief history of time of course by the
great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so long and
other things got in the way and it was
fantastic
to check it out on blinkist blinkist has
books on politics philosophy science
they have 27 different non-fiction
categories and a subscription
is only about eight bucks a month and
you get the entire
library but you can try it totally free
and get 25 off a subscription when you
go to blinkist.com
david pakman i've put the link right
underneath this video
so this week we've been learning just
little piecemeal
about what was taking place behind the
scenes in the prior administration at
the start of the pandemic one
completely off the wall bullet point
that we got
was that donald trump was looking at
sending
americans who were infected with the
virus to
the guantanamo bay detention center in
cuba i mean just completely out of this
world bonkers insanity
there is now a new report uh in slate
that summarizes
more of what we are increasingly
learning and it is
really wacky wacky stuff uh the slate
article
says the evidence of trump's pandemic
sabotage keeps piling up
a new book shows how he concealed the
crisis to protect his image and
it is unbelievable um the
article uh talks about uh this this uh
book by yasmin abudolab and damian
paletta
from the washington post and it points
out that they present their findings in
the new book nightmare scenario inside
the trump administration's response to
the pandemic that changed history
the book relies in part on interviews
with former trump officials
won't be available until june 29th but
there are excerpts quoted in the post
that describe
several incriminating episodes in at
least two cases trump tried to keep
infected americans from setting foot in
the united states
not to prevent the virus from spreading
but to prevent the infections from being
counted as part of trump's record
in one instance trump's opposition to
letting 14 americans return from a
cruise ship the diamond princess
the authors add backstage details trump
complained to alex azar his
secretary of health and human services
that the return
of the infected americans doubles my
numbers overnight
that was when trump was telling us that
15 cases would soon be zero
the authors report that trump tried to
fire the official who approved the
decision
the book also reveals a second episode
previously unreported
in which trump repeatedly proposed that
americans who had been infected
should be shipped to the u.s military
base at guantanamo bay cuba don't we
have an island we own trump asked
what about guantanamo the word island
was central to trump's idea according to
the authors he was eager to suppress the
numbers on u.s
soil and figured if you keep people off
the mainland they don't count
in both cases the infected citizens
could have been quarantined at
facilities in the continental us
that would have impeded the spread of
the virus but trump in his own words
viewed the presence of such people on
the mainland
as a threat to him statistically none of
this should
surprise us trump's biggest concern was
testing the authors right
by producing test kits for the virus and
administering them to more and more
americans doctors and the government
were gradually ascertaining the breath
of the crisis
trump chafed at this progress he said it
made him look bad
because he figured if people weren't
tested infections wouldn't be recorded
and it wouldn't be counted against him
the authors report a phone call to azar
testing is killing me i'm going to lose
the election
because of testing what idiot had the
federal government do
testing this is not new information
in the sense that these things were
previously reported
but the degree to which trump's sole and
primary focus
was how he would look and you know the
the unfortunate thing about all this is
that
trump doesn't care about anybody he
really doesn't trump doesn't care about
his own followers
trump doesn't care about even people who
support him he cares about them
as long as they're useful to him
politically and when they're not he
throws them in the trash like garbage
but the one aspect of this that could
have gone better would have been
if trump had realized at the beginning
the way to win this politically is by
doing what the doctors say
and doing you know look at how new
zealand dealt with the virus
look at how uh taiwan dealt with the
virus look at
there's other examples it was really
good for the leaders
and had trump at the beginning thought
hey
forget about the fact that he doesn't
care about people he never cared about
people
but if trump had said at the beginning
the best thing politically for me
is to manage this virus by doing a ton
of testing which helps people identify
if they're sick and stay home and not
spread the virus if he had done that it
would have been good for him politically
and as i've said many many times before
if donald trump had just done a passably
okay job on the virus
he would be president right now instead
of joe biden there's no question about
that whatsoever
but instead trump's concern was
sabotaging the spread of the virus
containment aspect in order to do what
he believed but
wrongly so that would look good and in
the end
it didn't help it actually was a
complete and total disaster
um just a couple of other things here
trump and his aides belittled and
resisted life-saving public health
measures obviously
the book reports that mark short a
veteran trump aide serving as
pence's chief of staff opposed a plan
to send free masks to every household on
the grounds that it would alarm the
public
senior trump officials ridiculed masks
likening them to a training bra
or underwear on your face short also
opposed the economic shutdown that
slowed the spread of the virus in march
and april
and on the rare occasions when trump
pushed subordinates to move more quickly
he did so for personal advantage not
public health
in the fall according to the book he
tried to oust fda commissioner stephen
hahn
for refusing to strong-arm fda
scientists into approving covet vaccines
before election day one anecdote
reported in the book
is more significant than it might seem
in late march of 2020 robert cadillac a
senior hhs official
went to trump's senior advisor and
son-in-law jared kushner
with a plan to mass distribute masks
when kushner learned the masks wouldn't
arrive until june he exploded we'll all
be dead by june he told cadillac
in the post's retelling this
conversation comes across
as a tale of delay and frustration but
it's worse than that
it shows how gravely kushner and others
in the white house privately viewed the
crisis
which trump was telling americans
publicly the virus would soon
disappear that is the epitome and a
microcosm of the entire handling of the
virus
we learned from the bob woodward
interview that trump did trump knew it
was more serious than he was letting on
he said he didn't want to scare people
jared kushner based on this anecdote
clearly knew privately
how serious it was uh everything that
they did was based on their worst into
instincts their most self-centered
instincts
and a complete and total lack of empathy
and concern i mean just a disgusting
expose
no individual incident is particularly
shocking
because what was going on publicly was
bad enough but i believe that
we will continue to learn more about
this just about every week
we're learning more about what was going
on and it's as disgusting as you can
imagine
roger stone is the former trump uh
confidante
aide who has also been a guest on this
program
roger stone of course was convicted and
then
pardoned by donald trump roger stone has
a new hypothesis
which is that it is the secret service
that was somehow involved in the trump
riots on january 6th now i have to admit
we're going to look at a clip of this
and if i'm totally honest with you i
don't
fully understand the conspiracy theory
here and
i kind of love it in the sense that one
of my favorite things
is a conspiracy theory that doesn't even
make any sense like it's hard to even
understand
there's lots of conspiracy theories
where you hear it and you say
that just doesn't sound like it's really
the way things are
but this is one where i'm left asking
what exactly is roger stone
even arguing here so let's start taking
a listen this is roger stone on
newsmax i'm not even sure what he's
claiming took place but it involves the
secret service let's take a listen i
call it
fake news hey roger did you on january 6
did you go in the building i would never
even left the grounds of the willard
hotel
yeah i came out in front of the hotel in
the morning for a brief period to
stretch my legs
you can watch the entire video a number
of patriots come up and
ask for selfies or patriots yeah
patriots really want
he's popular with the patriot movement
told me that they're praying for me
but no i was not even on the capitol i
do find it
odd that shortly after the president's
speech
the secret service contacted uh someone
who worked for me by phone
and told me that they wanted to escort
me to the capitol
i declined uh i was not what do you
think that was about
so i guess now what stone is saying is
an unprovoked call from the secret
service saying we'd like to bring you to
the capitol would maybe be
to implicate stone maybe that's what
they're saying that they wanted to
place stone there to then implicate him
in the riots even though he didn't have
anything to do with it
tell me if that's how you're
understanding this when you say that
that
it's was there something about that that
sounded fishy
well i've worked for three american
presidents the secret service
does not do political chores the secret
service
does not perform logistical tasks i find
it rather
suspicious to be honest with you it's
suspicious in what way do you believe
even the hosts are sort of unsure like
what exactly are you
you alleging here uh that
perhaps um insiders i'm trying to figure
out how to award this within the secret
service of the cia or other
organizations were involved nefariously
uh look i normally make that claim
because i don't know it but have but
understanding how the secret service
works obviously the
implication is that this is something
the president wanted
i'm sorry i declined i was with uh
pastor mark burns and reverend randy
coggins right
in my suite watching the whole thing
unfold on television
right so my other question yeah making
the k
so i guess the conspiracy theory is
the secret service so tucker carlson and
others have been saying it's the fbi
that was involved in the trump riots
roger stone is saying i believe i again
i'm
he we have to interpret it all because
he's being kind of cagey and weird about
it but
he's saying the secret service which
would not normally be involved in
something like this
tried to put me at the scene of the
crime
in order for me to later be implicated
or something like that now
of course we don't actually have proof
that this call even took place
if it did take place we don't have proof
that it was actually the secret service
there's no evidence for any of this but
it is another one of these
um conspiracy theories presented without
any evidence
and we'll see if this one also becomes
part of the referential record remember
with tucker carlson tucker
floated this idea that the fbi organized
the trump riots
and then the next day congressman louie
gomer demanded we look into it
even though tucker presented it without
any evidence that's how they do it
that's how they insert
narratives uh as fact which then become
referential in their future claims we'll
see if it happens with this one but
that's the latest
claim from roger stone the secret
service
it sounds like everybody other than
actual trumpists was involved it was the
secret service
it was the fbi it was antifa
dressed as trumpist but definitely no
trump is but at the same time it was
totally peaceful
um figure that one out
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a
member which gives you access to the
daily bonus show
the regular show with no commercials you
also get access to
our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpackman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for
a huge discount join pacman.com
all right let's talk a little bit about
the uh saturday night live situation
and then i have voicemail and then we've
got the bonus show and a lot of other
things
still to get to this is in a sense it's
not really a new story because it was
sort of offhandedly reported in 2019 but
now we're learning the full scope of
this uh donald trump actually did want
the uh satirical television program
saturday night live investigated
for making fun of him and of course
there's a couple of stories here one is
the incredibly
uh authoritarian perspective on what
should be allowed
in media in a country that supposedly
has
satirical media a free press etc we're
making fun of politicians including
presidents is something that you can do
that's
uh one piece of it the other part of it
is just trump is the endless victim with
like the thinnest possible skin
of anyone that we have ever heard of uh
so let's dig into this
um and look at it piece by piece there's
a great vanity fair article
um about this and the article is by best
levin
and it actually quotes the daily beast
which reported
it was the middle of donald trump's
presidency and he was
yet again mad at saturday night live and
he wanted the federal government
to help him settle the score in march of
2019 the then president of the united
states had just watched an episode of
the long-running liberal
leaning and nbc sketch comedy series
wasn't even a new episode it was a rerun
and grew immediately incensed that the
show was
gently mocking him it's truly incredible
that shows like saturday night live
not funny no talent can spend all of
their time
knocking the same person me over and
over
without so much of a mention of the
other side trump tweeted
long before he was banned from twitter
for inspiring a violent mob like an
advertisement without consequences same
with late night shows should federal
election commission
and or fcc look into this it was on its
face a ridiculous question and threat as
snl is obviously satire
and therefore a form of protected speech
in america that pissed off commanders in
chief have no authority to directly
subvert
however then president trump went
farther than simply tweeting his
displeasure with the late-night
comedians of
and snl writer's room the internal
discussions that followed between the
former leader of the free world
and some of his political and legal
advisors once again underscored
just how much trump wanted to use the
full weight
and power of the u.s government to
punish his personal enemies now of
course
the tweets we knew about from 2019 since
they were public
what's new is this additional piece
that we have now learned about according
to two people
familiar with the matter who spoke to
the daily beast
trump repeatedly asked lawyers and
advisers
what the fcc the court's systems
and the department of justice could do
to probe
or mitigate mitigate snl
jimmy kimmel live and other late night
shows
uh quoting the daily beast one source
who has a law degree
said that when they briefly discussed
this with trump more than two years ago
they made a point of saying that the
justice department in particular doesn't
handle these matters anyway
trump seemed disappointed to hear that
there was no actual legal recourse
or anything that the fcc or doj could do
to punish late-night anti-trump
comedy can something else be done about
it trump replied according to the source
to which they responded with some
version of i'll look into it
the person says they never actually
looked into it
this is horrifyingly authoritarian now i
know that there are many defenders of
trump who will hear this and they will
simply say oh it was just
he was just mad and he was just musing
he wasn't really saying anyone should
look into it
yes he was he was and he brought it up
multiple times
he was saying someone should look into
it fortunately no one did because it
would go completely counter to
everything that our country stands for
when it comes to speech and free press
and satire but
the the really it's not news to us that
donald
trump had extraordinarily authoritarian
authoritarian leaning tendencies we knew
that
the part that to me continues to be
stunning is that
this is the he was the most powerful
person in the world in the sense that
president of the united states
colloquially considered the leader of
the free world that
there is no one more powerful than the
american president
trump himself as a rich dude from new
york
has had an entire life of privilege and
power
and went above and beyond what any
president has ever done
in terms of trying to limit the
criticism of him
comedic criticism serious criticism on
news channels any of it
and uh just so extraordinarily thin
skinned now the one other thought i
don't
really care too much about this whole
like alpha male
beta male narrative that many
conservatives like
but if you buy into that narrative
um is this the behavior of an alpha male
i mean by
by those who like trump because they see
him
as an alpha and think about politicians
in those terms
is this how a so-called alpha male
behaves i think the answer is obviously
not saying go
could you and could we get the fcc to
investigate
the jokes being made about me absolutely
laughable that anybody would see donald
trump that way
and yes even though the authoritarianism
certainly shouldn't come as a surprise
to us because it's been one of trump's
hallmarks for a long time
it's still horrifying that he was
regularly trying to use the power of the
federal government
to do this stuff next i want to talk a
little bit about donald trump's reaction
so we already looked at the new reports
about donald trump
wanting saturday night live investigated
and looked into
for satirical content that they did
about donald trump
as they've been doing for president um
on presidents about presidents for
decades
my guess is that in the past when the
president was someone other than trump
trump didn't find anything wrong with
the satirical commentaries done by
saturday night live now whether you find
them funny or not
that's another question i'm not a big
snl guy
but it is without question whatsoever
that what they do
is completely protected constitutionally
and that having the federal government
look into it is absurd
donald trump yesterday put out another
one of these
statements where he denies the story
but sort of kind of like admits it in so
doing
let's take a look at this statement by
donald j
trump trump says the story that i asked
the department of justice to go after
ratings challenged
without trump saturday night live and
other late night losers
is total fake news it was fabricated
there were no sources and yet the lame
stream media goes with it
i did say however that alec baldwin has
no talent
certainly when it comes to imitating me
the one who had what it took was daryl
hammond
with this is a former president guys
with all of that being said however
i do believe that the 100 one-sided
shows should be considered an
illegal campaign contribution from the
democrat party
hard to believe i got 75 million votes
the most of any sitting president
despite all of that together with a very
fraudulent
election 2024 or
before so in it trump actually
does say he thinks that snl
should be illegal he is not saying
it should be illegal in the sense that
it's being reported that he wanted it
investigated but
he believes that it counts as a
democratic
campaign contribution i guess because
the show's existence has monetary value
to democrats
because they go after republicans but
not democrats now the truth is snl sort
of goes after both
it there is no doubt left-leaning it's
abundantly clear that it is a
left-leaning show
but no president has been exempt
from being targeted by snl but in
denying
that the story is a real story even
though
he tweeted this stuff out in 2019 he
tweeted this stuff out in the tweets
that i read to you in the previous
segment
he is saying actually there is
criminality in saturday night live which
is already completely off the wall
authoritarian and uh uh
suppressive of what are constitutionally
protected and not campaign contribution
satirical segments on snl it's so
funny how this guy in trying to deny
stuff he often ends up confirming that
at least the belief is true and of
course when you publicly tweet it out
it all is perfectly believable now trump
also put out one other statement
yesterday
um and these statements are so bizarre
trump wrote georgia now plans to remove
over 100 000 obsolete and outdated names
off their voter rolls doing this they
say will ensure voting files are up to
date while at the same time ensuring
voter integrity in future elections
but what about the last election why
wasn't this done prior to the november
3rd presidential election where they had
us losing
by a very small number of votes many
times less
than the 101 thousand 789 figure
this means we you won the presidential
election in georgia
but don't fret much other information
will soon be revealed about georgia and
other states as well it is coming out
fast
and furious the 2020 presidential
election
was rigged just a a word
salad of further uh
claims that he really won and
complaints that even though what george
is doing now is good
uh they should have done it before
because in reality he actually won
georgia i mean
it is endless with this guy and again
referencing
it's all going to come out very very
soon
um very unstable very unstable
and continuing to just put out what are
the equivalent of tweets
and this guy is going to do everything
he can
to play a celebrity role in 2022. he
wants to be revered
he wants a 2022 candidates
to come to him and pay a pilgrimage
whether it is a literal one or a digital
one or a figurative one or whatever the
case may be
he wants to be the decider for 2022 and
he is so desperate to be that
and continuing to allude to soon we are
going to learn the truth about 2020. now
really funny
mike lindell of my pillow just as a
quick update who has been saying for a
couple of weeks now
trump will be reinstated in august he
has now
shifted to saying i might be off by a
month
i might be off by a month so now mike
lindell's august
is becoming september why well august is
only five weeks away
and obviously trump is not going to be
back in five weeks
nor in nine weeks which would be the end
of august so already mike lindell is
starting to push back a little bit
and point to september they're gonna do
this all the way until they just say hey
you know what
we've got to just vote in 2022. that's
the way to do it so that then we can
impeach biden
and so then trump can come back in 2024.
it was written on the wall all along
and it's becoming increasingly clear
from these very strange statements
from donald trump we have a voicemail
number that number is 2192 david p
this is an example of a lot of what's
wrong with this country now i'm going to
warn you guys i'm going to play
something that's pretty ugly
um if there's kids in the room you may
want to get them out or
whatever the case may be based on your
personal sensibilities on this stuff i'm
about to play a pretty ugly voicemail
that tells us a lot of what is wrong
with this country take a listen
hey dave i'm just calling cause i wanted
to become a member
no i'm just kidding you i'm not a [ __ ]
just wondering if you ever listen back
to your shows and and
realize how much of a shield you are
and a weak pathetic man i assume by
she'll he means shill right i mean i
just i'm trying to figure that out
okay hold on let me go but i missed just
a few seconds of that how much of a
shield you are
and a weak pathetic man just curious
there it is so as you can see
uh not a particularly substantive
critique
we get 3 000 messages like that every
day now not voicemails right so you've
if you've got to look at email tweets
facebook posts instagram comments
and of course youtube and twitch
comments but 3 000 a day
that are somewhere in the arena
of stuff like that these are not folks
you can talk sense into
so we've got to figure out a way to win
despite them
we're with them is just not realistic
we've got to win despite them
and uh there are a lot of them there are
a lot of them today on the bonus show we
will talk about west nile
positive mosquitoes found in texas what
does it mean
we will also talk about morgan stanley
the company
will be banning unvaccinated workers at
their offices starting soon we'll talk
about why in the legal infrastructure
and russia wants to send cosmonauts
to china i'm sorry to the chinese space
station not to try
i guess they could go to china to the
chinese space station
we will talk about this possible new
outer space alliance and
again i mean as if we needed more
reasons to invest in space exploration
um maybe some of the right wingers will
get behind it because russia and china
are getting
together on the issue all of those
stories and more
on today's bonus show sign up at
joinpakman.com and get instant access
i'll see you then
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
blast light is the world's smallest and
most convenient
uvc disinfection light to help keep you
safe
against covid19 i take mine everywhere i
go
go to davidpakman.com slash blast
light to get it for forty percent off
the link is down below
blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
non-fiction book in just 15 minutes
you can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription
by going to blinkist.com david
pakman